hello everyone and welcome to day four
of the Grantchester is your next move a
tournament in Leuven the three days of
rapid are over and now we have two days
of blitz this is a game from round five
it's a blitz game between lebanon which
won a ton Anand all right it's really a
crazy game and it's also one of the
reasons why sometimes it's really nice I
had to take a break from classical chess
we're not gonna analyze it too much
since it's a blitz game but we are gonna
show some very nice tactics and before
we check out the game we don't have a
nice photo challenge so hope you did
well in the previous one and this one
will not be so easy as so far I think
I've only done one video on this player
but you should know who he is
there was I believe there was a show
about 10 of the most famous chess
players you've never heard of and this
person was a I believe number 10 so
maybe some of you may know him
here it is best of luck to everyone so
his story is quite quite a sad one and a
lot of people they say Morphy was the
the joy and sorrow of chess but this
man's story will also make guys are very
sad so for those of you who were able to
you know figure out congratulations your
knowledge truly is vast and I have done
one video on a game between him and josé
raúl capablanca so if you figure out who
this person is you are welcome to check
out this video so let's check this game
out our and it has the white pieces and
he opens with E 4 we have E 5 Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 sorry about that just
second Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 and
here are none did not to go for the
Evans gambit rather he played d3 we have
Knight to f6
so the Italian game is on the board
Joker pianissimo we have castles d6 c3 a
6-1 IBD 2 we have castles by Anand
Bishop to b3 rook to e8 rook to e1 and
to e6 so it's only moved nine but
Ireland's next move is is a brilliant
one and you know it's hard to imagine
such a move can can exist in a position
like this here are none played Bishop
the c2 he avoids the trade of bishops
but this move is actually a terrible
blunder why Bishop the c2 is a terrible
blunder well you'll just have to pause
the video and try to figure it out for
ourselves so it's only moved ten but
here Anand has a crushing move so I will
give it a couple of seconds as usual you
know for those of you who are able to
find it congratulations you are really
an excellent attacker and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy a show here
comes Knight to g4 and the knight the g4
is a is a great move because it really
takes advantage of the fact that the
only piece of defending the bishop on c2
is actually the Queen so you know it
seems like the bishop is a very well
defended and you know how are you gonna
get the bishop but it really reminds me
of a game between Greg and needs and
Michael Tao well are aware Greg I need
to play the weird rook move and tell so
that nothing was actually guarding that
rook so if you want to check out that
video it's also an excellent game it's a
very old video but I will put a link to
it in the description below so you can
check that out as well if you're
interested quite a lovely tale game so
nice to G for simply attacking the f2
pawn and now the only way you can defend
the f2 point is by rookie - or rock f1
it doesn't matter what you play arjan
played rook to e2 and now comes Bishop
captures on f2 and this is with the
check so of course you don't want to
play King f1 then 93 is coming but even
if you play King H 1 again 93 is coming
the Queen has nowhere to go
the bishop and the night are covering
all of the squares so we have to capture
it and now black is up the exchange and
up upon white is completely busted
so after Bishop captures on f2 RN and
saw that he has to capture it so we have
rook captures and now Knight e3
attacking but the Queen the Queen has to
move and now you see the problem with
this Bishop to see to move the bishop on
c2 is really undefended
so Queen to e2 we have nice capture
sense
- and now rook to be one as the rook was
attacked Bishop captures an A - and now
Aaron cannot save this rook but he can
play b3 mmm we have Bishop capture son
be one night capture some b1 now
trapping this night in situ so the
knight can't really escape but okay we
have nice to d4 seek after son d4 Knight
capture Sundy for attacking the Queen
Knight captures and B capture Sundy for
if you look at this position iron and
thus have a knight and the bishop for a
rook but Anand is up three pawns
so with so many pawns and rook against
two pieces on indefinitely is is better
here so after night - D - we have c5 we
have Queen - gee Quinn - g4 iron is
planning Knight f3 and then the bishop
will be able to attack the black King
via Bishop to h6 we have Queen to see a
ton and offers a trade of Queens a queen
g3 already on the clients and now d5 we
have Knight to f3 and here we have the
first the first bad move by anand d
captures on e4 immediately allowing our
not to take on to continue with the
attack
we have bush up to h6 now there's the
threat of checkmate Queen captures and
g7 g 6 is the only move that defends
this threat and now comes Knight to g5
attacking the f7 pawn and there's no way
you can allow this of course but it's
very hard to defend it if you play
something like rookie 7 and Knight
captures an e4 is coming then the thread
is knife to f6 you can't all-out this
and here black would have to capture the
night and and white would simply be up a
piece but after this Knight G to a5 move
on and played an even worse move he
played f5 and here I want you to pause
the video again and well try to figure
out why why this is a blunder
Aragon missed that Oregon didn't find it
well try to find it and I will get a
couple of seconds as usual for those of
you who found this congratulations you
are an excellent exploiter of the
seventh rank
and for those who just want to enjoy it
show the idea is rook captures on f5 so
of course you cannot allow rook to f7
then Luke g7 Rock h7 all of these ideas
become possible and there's a really no
good way to prevent this I feel if you
try something like Queen captures the
rook which is of course the main idea if
you don't if you play pawn captures then
Knight captures on at 8 on h7 will
decide the game but if Queen captures
now you can see that Queen to c7 there
is no defense against Quinta g7
checkmate okay if you can block this but
then you get Queen - h7 checkmate it
doesn't really matter but after f5 we
have D captors on e5 RN misses this and
he grabs a pawn and now Anand misses his
opportunity to defend and now Queen to
d7 is the only defense because now
either he captures an f5 then rook e1
and black is fine you have to block
captures captures and now this captures
the pawn or after Queen to d7 the rook
f5 idea no longer works because now you
can capture the rook there are no useful
discoveries and after Knight captures
which was the winning attack in the
previous variation here King captures
and there is no more checkmate on g7
because the queen is not protecting it
but after D captures on c4 Aragon grab
the pawn and then Anand did not defend
precisely rather he played c4 and now
you know giving it a second try Aragon
does find rook captures on f5 so rook
captures on f5 and there is really no
good defense here so you cannot allow
rook to f7 I'm going to try capturing it
but now you get the knife captures on h7
grabbing the night with the resulting
Queen g7 checkmate the so after night to
h7 we have King to f7 now Queen to g7
check King e6 Queen to f6 so the King
hunt is on King the 7 now Queen chapter
74 check King c7 Bishop f4 check the
King is running out of squares
king c6 and now Queen captures on c4 and
it was in this position on move 32 that
Vishwanathan are not resigned the game
why did he resign well the only two
options King b6 and King d7 result in
checkmate in two so if you try came to
be sick
then of course you get a bishop III
check King moves and now Queen to a4
will be checkmate and if you try after
Queen to see for King to d7 then you get
Queen d6 check King moves and now Bishop
to Bishop to g5 will be checkmate as the
knight is covering the f8 square so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
it's quite you know it was a brilliant
how I took advantage of that you know
seemingly harmless move Bishop to c2 he
immediately punished it with Knight to
g4 and then he allowed this monstrosity
of an attack and lastly a king hunt but
such is the way of blitz so now I once
again I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon with at least one more game
from this lovely blitz event in Leuven
and you know and we're gonna check out
the standings the final game while I
show and then I'm gonna include the
standings as well after the first day of
weights so thank you all and I'll see
you soon
best of luck with the photo challenge